Oh
[Music]
so I thought I knew all the really big
Disney Channel movies like High School
Musical xenon and so forth but after I
did the Disney cember focusing on the
Disney Channel movies everyone seemed to
say I miss Lemonade Mouth how could you
not talk about Lemonade Mouth
everybody knows Lemonade Mouth and yeah
I never even heard of it
but sure enough I got a copy took a look
and the hell did I just watch the set up
for this movie you can so easily see on
a chart in some executives office
what if The Breakfast Club had a rock
band that's pretty much it a bunch of
anti-authority teens who are really good
deep down in their hearts but are always
fighting against the evil bad principal
who just doesn't get the joke no really
they say that a lot in this lemonade
mouth is a movement yeah this is less of
a movement and more of that Saved by the
Bell episode where they go into the
history of their band yeah remember that
was an episode with all the
stereotypical band cliches it's pretty
much what this is a group of absolutely
beautiful kids all get in trouble for
various reasons thus they're all sent to
detention on the same day and wouldn't
you know it they all happen to have
incredible musical abilities the music
teacher really wants to utilize their
talents and put them in a band so that
she can really stick it to the big bad
principal who just cares about getting
sponsorships for sports teams but dude
that's not what they really want to do
they were just horsing around
or do they overtime they think about and
decide they do want to put a band
together but there's a big bed you will
ban who's even more popular and
constantly tries to sabotage them and
wouldn't you know it
they're in cahoots with the principal
well wait I thought you was cutting
funding to the music program because it
didn't get enough people looking at it
but everyone seems to know this group
when it's discovered the good guys band
is gonna play alongside them shortening
their run the whole entire school that's
pissed off at them well wait a minute if
the whole entire school knows who they
are they get angry at this clearly there
would be money behind it oh let's make
more people are into this band than they
are basketball or football however when
the big bad band is making
one of them one of them takes a big gulp
of lemonade and spits at Adam resulting
in their band name lemonade mouth of
course they of course turn out to be a
big hit but they don't want to do this
for the music they want do it cuz they
have something important to say like how
they're actually gonna take away the
lemonade vending machine what first of
all have you ever seen a sign on a
vending machine that says it's gonna be
moved who does that
second who gives a shit you see your
talk in front of the whole audience
saying like yeah they're gonna get rid
of the lemonade vending machine and
bring in this other one that's like a
corporate sponsor and everyone's like
boo what she tries to turn into this big
movement that the school is too
controlled by the sponsorship but the
big bad principal shuts it down they're
too dangerous the school is just so
excited about their movement that they
keep putting signs everywhere even this
giant banner that this guy for the life
of him can't get down look at this is he
even trying no it's right lightly
tugging on it let me try lightly tugging
out some more maybe if I kind of push it
no it didn't work maybe if I push it
didn't work maybe if I push it what it's
this movie and then everything and I do
mean quite literally everything
simultaneously goes wrong one of them
loses their voice the other gets
allergies the other has family problems
the other like smashes his fingers like
what are the chances but it's okay when
they get to the big climax at the end
where they're supposed to play they all
show that's right none of them can do it
some of them get the nerves or they're
just thrown off or whatever but the
audience sings the song for them and
next thing you know they're at Madison
Square Gardens happen
you're literally so bad the crowd has to
sing the song for you and suddenly
you're landing this gig I mean I'm sure
time is suppose to a past and everything
but come on that's kind of a big edit I
think a few other things would happen in
between so yeah as you'd imagine this
movie's pretty stupid I can't say it's
quite Camp Rock too bad or Cheetah Girls
bad I mean it is really dumb but it is
kind of enjoyable how dumb it is I'll
also give a credit that it is trying to
tackle something of substance I mean the
kids do have some real
problems they talk about them they try
to figure them out I like the idea of
questioning school authority I mean when
you think about it you actually don't
see that too much in Disney Channel
films but all of it just feels so phony
and manipulative none of it feels real
you just feel like they're trying to
tell a g-rated version of behind the
music sometimes it results in some real
good laughs though Christopher McDonald
for example has made a whole career out
of being the bully he just has the look
he has the mannerisms he has the acting
for it he always plays this part but
he's done it so much he's kind of turned
into Nelson from The Simpsons he's just
this archetype but really has fun with
it and he is hilarious in this he knows
exactly what he's supposed to be and he
goes beautifully over the top with it
look at him on this Segway how many
hours must he have spent on this thing
to get these movements down it's just
hilarious it's rough on the one hand I
really want to support something that
says stand up to Authority and be aware
of manipulation but this is coming from
an authoritative company that is
manipulating you and it's doing a really
bad job hiding it and it's corny and
it's silly and it's forceful and none of
it makes sense at all I guess I would
probably put this in the camp rock group
or it's just so ridiculous and dumb that
it's kind of funny I can't think of any
particular bad messages being said at
least if I don't think too hard about
them
I get the feeling the actors are trying
to get across something genuine but it
just never feels that way you're always
aware of the Disney stamp you're always
aware that it's a Disney Channel movie
and you're always aware it's trying to
sell you this group not start a movement
it's pretty lame but I had a few
chuckles at how lame it was if this is
something that really inspired you and
helped you start a movement good for you
go fight the man but if you're a kid
searching for artistic integrity
you're probably gonna get more laughs
than provoking thoughts
[Music]
you